le kremlin suit de près l'évolution de
la situation avec les sanctions
occidentales a affirmé le porte-parole
du président russe dmitri peskov
la russie va respecter le principe de
réciprocité
un imposant les sanctions en réponse aux
restrictions américaines et européennes
dmitri peskov a également déclaré que
les autorités russes étaient prêtes à
faire face à de nouvelles sanctions qui
seront sans doute imposer je vous
propose d'écouter
bien sûr nous suivons de près tous les
rapports de ce genre qui ne sont pour
l'instant que des rapports des médias
nous comprenons en même temps qu étant
donné le mécanisme mis en place à
washington les états unis vont annoncer
de nouvelles sanctions il s'agit
d'accusations gratuites et infondées
selon lesquelles la russie posséderait
des stocks d'armes chimiques sur son
territoire il n'y a pas de données
crédibles qui lundi qu il ne peut pas y
en avoir car la russie a détruit tous
ses stocks
il ya longtemps et arrêter tous les
programmes de production d'armes
chimiques
en vertu de son obligation découlant de
la convention d'interdiction des armes
chimiques
la russie le comprend et en tient compte
elle envisage divers scénarios afin de
protéger des intérêts du pays et de ses
citoyens de la manière la plus efficace
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe
mariya zakharova a quant elle pointé du
doigt le soutien de l'opposition russe
par les pays occidentaux selon elle
l'union européenne qui ne ménage pas ses
efforts en faveur de l'opposition en
russie négligent en revanche ces
problématiques internes que ce soit le
cas des gels et jaune ou la sphère
julian assange
écoutez malheureusement de nombreux pays
de l'union européenne joue à la fermeté
de principe
cela concerne de nombreuses questions
les relations avec la russie
l'incapacité et l'impossibilité de
défendre leur principe sous pression
américaine
cela s'applique également à la
problématique des droits de l'homme
étant donné qu'ils ont déployés en
faveur de notre position hors système
un véritable arsenal une argumentation
des possibilités de soutien en termes
politiques d'information mêle de tout
vous voyez qu'une offensive est en cours
washington et bruxelles ont annoncé le 2
mars des sanctions à l'encontre de
plusieurs hauts responsables russes
en réponse alain posément présumé et
l'emprisonnement de l'opposant russe
alexeï navalni des mesures de moscou a
souligné l'inefficacité